معنا من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل
ابو عمر اسماعيل يوم دموي جديد اطلعنا على
اخر
تطوراته اخر تطورت منذ صباح هذا اليوم
وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تتغير وتيره اطلاق
قذائف من قبل اليات الاحتلال في مناطق
مختلفه من محافظه خنوس وتركيز هذه القذائف
باتجاه المناطق الغربيه للمحافظه في محيط
مستشفى ناصر وكذلك محيط مستشفى الامل تابع
ل جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في حي
الامل الى الشمال الغربي من معسكر خانيونس
وكل هذه المناطق تتواجد فيها اليات
الاحتلال وتطلق النيران ايضا باتجاه منازل
المواطنين وتحركات المواطنين احيانا الذين
يحاولون في اكثر من مره ال الخروج من تلك
المناطق التي باتت مناطق خطيره جدا بسبب
تواجد اليات الاحتلال وهناك مخاوف على
حياه هؤلاء المواطنين المتواجدين داخل
سواء معسكر خانيونس او حتى في منطقه حي
الامل المشروع وكذلك في المدارس الكثيره
التي تاوي نازحين بالالاف في محيط مستشفى
ناصر وكذلك في محيط منطقه الصناعه او مركز
التدريب التابع للوكاله الامم المتحده وفي
منطقه حي الامل في المشروع هناك ايضا
مدارس في الحي الياباني تؤوي الاف
النازحين هؤلاء اصبحت هناك خطوره على
حياتهم في ظل هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي و
حاصره اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمثل هذه
المناطق سواء في حي المشروع وكذلك في
منطقه معسكر خان يونس في محيط مستشفى ناصر
الغارات لم تتوقف منذ الصباح كان قبل قليل
هناك غاره اسرائيليه نفذتها طائرات
الاحتلال في وسط محافظه خانيونس وكان هناك
سماع ايضا لطلقات ناريه اطلقتها طيرات
الاحتلال من نوع اباتشي
باتجاه اهداف في وسط المحافظه ايضا كان
هناك استهداف وعمليات نسف قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال في وسط محافظه خميس كذلك في
الاجزاء الجنوبيه الشرقيه وكذلك الاجزاء
الشرقيه تعرضت لعمليات قصف برغم انسحابات
جزئيه قامت بها اليه الاحتلال من تلك
المناطق خاصه في بني سهيله وكذلك منطقه
معن ولكن التحرك في تلك المناطق هناك
خطوره في تحركات المواطنين الذين يحاولون
الوصول الى منازلهم وممتلكاتهم في تلك
المناطق من اجل الاطمئنان على هذه المنازل
ومحاوله جلب ما يمكن جلبه من تلك المنازل
ل اماكن النزوح التي يتواجدون فيها في
مناطق رفح وكذلك مناطق غرب خانيونس لكن
نتحدث بان وتيره الاشتباكات في في منطقه
معسكر خانيونس وكذلك في منطقه حي الامل
بشكل كبير جدا ترتفع حده هذه الاشتباكات
بين ساعه واخرى المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحاول
ان تتصدى لاليات الاحتلال باطلاق قذائف
مضاده للدروع وهذا ما اعنت عنه عبر ب غات
مختلفه خلال الساعات الماضيه حيث قال ب
انها تصدت لاكثر من اربعه اليات او خمسه
اليات في منطقه غرب خانيونس
كذلك استهداف لاليات الاحتلال في منطقه حي
الامل واطلاق قذائف هام باتجاه تحش و
تمركزات اليات الاحتلال في اكثر من منطقه
في خانيونس كذلك كان هناك اطلاق قذاف هوم
تجاه تجمعات الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال في
منطقه الفخاري الى اقصى الجنوب الشرقي
لمحافظه خانون عموما اعداد الشهداء في
محافظه خنوس في هذا اليوم
تجاوز الار شهيدا خاصه نتحدث هناك شهداء
تم نقل تم دفنهم داخل مقر او مركز تدريب
الصناعه التابع للامم المتحده في غرب
خانيونس 14 شهيدا اضافه الاصابات التي تم
التنسيق لاخراجها من هذا المقر باتجاه
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار في مدينه رفح بعد
ان استطاعت طواقم الاسعاف الوصول الى هذا
المقام بعد تنسيق قامت به الوكاله
والانروا وكذلك الصليب الاحمر لدخول هذه
الاسعافات لنقل المصابين من داخل هذا
المقر باتجاه مستشفيات مدينه رفح واليات
الاحتلال ما زالت تحاصر هذا المقر وتحاصر
ايضا عديد المدارس في تلك المنطقه ابلغنا
قبل قليل بان احدى المدارس تم اقتحامها من
قبل قوات الاحتلال واجبرت المواطنين
والنازحين للخروج من هذه المدرسه والتحرك
باتجاه مستشفى نص
شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلنا اسماعيل ابو عمر من
خونس